okay so in this quick video here we're
gonna go over the ecological levels of
organization so let's go ahead and get
started alright so let's go ahead and
start with the most basic level of
ecological organization which is called
a population you know in the picture we
have a bunch of rabbits here and this
would be an example of a population it's
a group of the same species all living
in the same area and so what have we
learned well we've learned that
populations have a limit you know you
may have heard the expression that
rabbits can reproduce like rabbits they
make more they reproduce in an abundant
rate but there's what we've seen is that
nature limits the amount of reproduction
that can occur what we've seen is that
environments typically have our
populations typically have a carrying
capacity it's the greatest number of
individuals that the environment can
sustain there are limiting factors there
are factors that prevent the
overpopulation of rabbits you know for
instance there's a lack of resources
eventually there's just not enough food
for all the rabbits to survive this can
lead to competition competition for food
for water for mates for living spaces
and as populations get larger and larger
and larger more individuals brings more
disease and let's not forget that
wherever rabbits live there's probably
predators that are trying to eat the
rabbits and so for that reason
populations have a limit they have what
we call a carrying capacity let's zoom
out to the next level of ecological
organization
when we zoom out a little bit we come to
a level called the community and this
level is defined as an area where there
are many populations living
so not just rabbits also plant life like
grasses plant life such as trees birds
maybe nesting in these trees and lurking
in the shadows maybe some predators
symbolized by my wolves so this is more
realistic of a community and so what
have we learned by studying communities
well we've learned that each species an
individual has its own habitat you know
the birds are nesting in the trees the
rabbits are digging through the ground
burrowing and and building their homes
and we also learned that organisms have
their own niche a niche is like a role
or a lifestyle that the organism
occupies for instance the Wolves are
predators you know that's their niche
and then you have the rabbits or
herbivores and other animals that are
not pictured here it could be omnivores
and other forms of life that are not
pictured here could be decomposers you
know one reason why you can have two
species of birds living in the same
trees because they have a different
niche the blue birds for instance may
build their nest in the autumn months
and eat insect a the reddish pinkish
birds however might build their nests in
the spring and eat insect B because
they're not in direct competition with
another one another they're able to
coexist their niches do not overlap with
one another if their niches were to
overlap you would see competition zoom
out we come to our next level called
the ecosystem and what's different with
the ecosystem what are we adding well
we're adding the living and the
non-living factors in this environment
right now we have a community because
all the organisms pictured are living
but in an ecosystem let's say we add
some nonliving rocks we add some
nonliving water now we have an ecosystem
and so what have we learned by studying
eco systems what we've learned is that
the biotic life is affected by the a by
which that simply means that life is
affected by nonliving factors you know
for instance drought if there's a time
period of extreme drought well this
could reduce the ability for plants to
grow another example of would be for
instance the rocks release phosphorous
which is part of the phosphorous cycle
and so rocks which are nonliving release
phosphorus into the soil and once
phosphorus is in the soil plants can
grow and you have it part of a healthy
ecosystem
well we've also learned that it goes the
other way too is that the nonliving
parts of the environment are affected by
the living so the abiotic is affected by
the biotic great examples of this would
be you know humans and our polluting of
waterways you know humans were a living
organism and we pollute nonliving
waterways another example would be
decompose a positive example right here
would be decomposers living decomposers
bacteria and fungus living decomposers
they enrich the soil with nutrients
soils not living and so these are great
examples of how the abiotic factors are
affected by the biotic factors let's
zoom out to the next level of ecology
when we zoom out to the next level of
ecology we come to a biome a biome is a
large area of land with a distinct
climate plant life and animal life you
know so what have we learned by studying
biomes well we've learned that the
climate of an area determines where life
can survive you know the the biome that
you see here that includes northern
United States and Canada is the biome
called the taiga you know the taiga is
characterized by a lack of water during
the long cold winter months you know
this prevents broadleaf trees and plants
from growing in the taiga you also see
very few if any cold-blooded animals you
don't really see a lot of snakes and you
don't really see a lot of salamanders
cold-blooded organisms have a really
hard time living in these environments
another biome picture right here is even
further north this would be the tundra
and again the tundra is characterized by
even colder and drier conditions and
this prevents much of any kind of life
from living in the tundra yeah you'll
see you scattered plans and scattered
animals but for the most part the tundra
is a very life is very rare in the
tundra let's zoom out we come to the
final level of ecology called the
biosphere this is the part of the earth
where we can find life you know the
picture here are all the biomes of the
earth the deserts and the Tundra's and
the Tyga's and the tropical rainforests
you know all the biomes combined make up
our biosphere and it stretches from the
depths of the ocean to about 11 miles
1011 miles up into the atmosphere above
that we don't really see any life and so
what have we learned by studying the
biosphere we've learned that changes to
the biosphere can affect life one of the
best examples of this is what we see
with pollution and human action you know
for the past few centuries humans if we
look at this picture of the earth here
have been putting out a whole bunch of
extra amounts of carbon dioxide into the
atmosphere and we're seeing some global
effects of this we're seeing
temperatures and climate patterns
altered around the entire earth great
example of how the biosphere can be
affected by life okay I'd like to leave
you with this picture here of this
pyramid to kind of sum up what we've
talked about you know a population is a
group of one species and that fits
inside of a community which are many
species communities fit inside of
ecosystems and many ecosystems fit
inside of a biome and there's several
dozen biomes that fit inside of the
biosphere so these are the levels of
ecological organization you know post
your comments and thoughts in the space
below perhaps I'll get a chance to
respond to some of them thanks for
watching